Daniel Schorr author of staying tuned
you write about a lot of episodes in
your life including the pike committee
tell us that story
well the pike committee was a house
intelligence committee headed by
representative Otis Pike of New York
they had joined the Senate in an
investigation of CIA FBI and some other
bad things that had happened before then
the House committee headed by
congressman Pike completed a report
voted nine to forth to publish the
report and I happen to get an advance
draft of it from that draft I simply
reported on the air this report says the
report quotes or no the report has to
give this net all the rest of it at one
point on television I actually held up
the report so this is the report which
is going to be issued next week and but
it wasn't issued next week because the
house decided in its wisdom that it
would suppress the report that left me
in the strange position of having the
only copy of the report in the free
world if I may put it that way
and people began calling me and saying
who's shown us on television this will
never be published unless you publish it
I know Maya that's a lot of
responsibility well I went to my bosses
at CBS which owned two publishing houses
and said why don't we do like what the
New York Times did with the Pentagon
Papers having reported these stories and
then then published for historians a
text of it why don't we do that
CBS made clear that it wasn't going to
do that because the New York Times and a
television network are very different in
terms of what they're worried about
regulations and all of that thereupon
arms will have to do it by myself and
with the help of the reporters committee
for freedom of the press I said find
somebody who will publish the whole
thing and I'll give it to them that
turned out to be the Village Voice there
was a big uproar not only from the Ford
administration from the CIA from
Secretary Henry Kissinger but alas also
within CBS where the affiliates happened
at devastators 1976 and the affiliates
were very worried in those days about
cable coming
and they were worried about the
legislation that might help cable they
didn't want to have somebody from
television somewhere having a problem
creating a problem for them with the
Congress of all things at that time and
so the result of that was that the
affiliates asked for my head they wanted
me fired
CBS first suspended me and then at some
point at some point asked me to sign an
agreement to resign at the end of
congressional investigations the House
Ethics Committee got the job of finding
out where I had gotten the report and
they tried they had a bunch of FBI X FBI
agents were hired they interviewed the
staff the members of the committee
anybody who might have it and they
didn't get anywhere and eventually they
decided they would subpoena me and ask
me simply where did I get it well I
appeared in a public session with the
thanks heaven a public television camera
there which I think made a big
difference
and they demanded to know where I gotten
the report on pain of contempt of
Congress citation which might have
resulted in a couple of years in jail it
was very serious nonetheless I had no
way but to say that I can't do this and
in the end they voted six to five not to
cite me for contempt but instead to
denounce me for all the terrible things
that I had done did you ever tell
anybody where you got that no of course
not nor will I now now if somebody had
me gave it to you it was dead would you
say would you tell us where it came from
Bob Woodward has said that that he will
tell who deep throat is when deep throat
is has died I haven't even approached
that question no I don't think so I
think when you promise us a source
confidentiality that doesn't end with
death now that you ask what was the
story about Leslie Stahl I remember
years ago that there was a riff inside
your Bureau because you had done
something of blaming Leslie Stahl for
this well the one stupid thing in the
one thing I regret having done although
it was very well men having decided that
to provide an extra
layer of protection for my source I
would also try to be anonymous myself
interposing them well the result of that
there's also that was that since it
wasn't clear where this report had come
from when the Village Voice published it
people began speculating on one of these
speculations went like this it was in
the Village Voice the man who wrote the
introduction to it for the Village Voice
was quoting Lesley Stahl
Aaron Latham Aaron Latham he was
frequently at our office waiting for
Leslie to finish work so we're in the
middle of our newsroom
we Xerox extra copies of the report and
so there was the hypothetical
possibility since I had not immediately
said that I did it but hypothetical
possibility that it might have in some
way been Aaron Latham Leslie Stahl as
soon as I realized where where that
speculation was going I went in to the
our bureau chief in the way to it cut
that out a lot you will very soon know
just let me talk to a lawyer so it'll be
lawyer client and within 24 hours I made
clear to them that they were the source
they were looking for it was myself what
year was all this all this with 1976 and
what impact did it have on your current
CBS well what I meant was it was
interesting after my appearance before
the House Ethics Committee
the CBS my bosses of CBS which is the
land who had caused me to sign more or
less an undated letter of resignation
now changed his mind and asked me to go
back to work and as a particular ad me
in last February he said well then I'm
unfollowing you now but I said I think
that we've gone too far my lawyer and
friend Joe Califano
said you don't have any future there
anymore after all of that and so I took
my resignation which they had now had to
let me resign because they had me closed
to write that letter of resignation and
I resigned with it with a very good
financial settlement how many years did
you work at CBS and what were they they
were there
I was hired on the abolition of ed
Murrow in 1953 I had been the CBS
stringer before then hired in 1953 I
left 1976 so it was 23 years of actual
work plus two more years I remained on
the on the payroll because my contract
had to still to go on you also report in
your book on an incident that happened
two years earlier when Richard Nixon
resigned yes August the 9th August the
8th he resigned over 90 actually left
the White House in which you say it had
a direct impact on your future at CBS
well that's right
I had I was what was called CBS's chief
Watergate correspondent and as we
approached the time of either
impeachment or resignation so we were
getting ready for the end of the regime
of Richard Nixon however it came about I
was assigned with a young producer to
produce something called the political
obituary of Richard Nixon and that was
the trace Watergate all through right
after this which we want to play on
whatever night it was that they that the
end came what happens train thing happen
all the Taylor who was then the
president of CBS incorporated came to
town he had campaigned for Nixon in
college he came to town I assume or why
he was there and he said they were very
worried about what Nixon might say in
his resignation that he might unload on
television in general and CBS in
particular and polarized the country on
the subject of television and CBS and he
was very worried about that
I saw him later that afternoon and he
said he was no longer worried about that
they thought they had it in hand I
assumed that meant that he had talked to
friends at the White House and has some
sort of understanding that began to
become more sure when the bureau chief
our bureau chief came to us six on the
clock from the evening as we waited for
the nine o'clock announcement came to us
and said look he said to me Dan don't be
vindictive tonight by the way talking
about vindictive we were just going to
do our job
what does that mean
and then suddenly instruct me that
somebody was trying to send word out
that we should not be unduly harsh with
Nixon on this night and most of my
colleagues weren't in fact one after
another severide rather than the rest of
them made remarks about this is maybe
his finest hour they were his
resignation and the way his leaving all
the rest of it everybody except Roger
Mudd who was up on Capitol Hill and
presumably was not given these marching
orders to be very nice well on the big
political obituary which which we had
done was scrapped and in general I
thought CBS behaved which had done very
well in covering this up until that
point was behaving in a very peculiar
fashion as though there was the kind of
a spoken or unspoken understanding with
Nixon that will be nice to you you be
nice to us and indeed that was the way
it seemed well I expressed my suspicions
about that evening in public which is
something you don't do if you hope to
advance your career and I expressed it
and they got very very angry with me
and that probably this was 1974 this was
two years before the final split off
probably that episode of my having lost
confidence in CBS at the climax of the
whole Nixon whole Nixon episode probably
caused more anger against me and
probably laid the way for my being fired
or resigned however you want to put it
you say in your book you say I expressed
my dark suspicions and a newspaper
interview in Denver and a bull session
with students at Duke University the
next line is severide never spoke to me
again
yes never ever did he speak to others
about you oh yes oh yes
what'd he say I mean why was he so mad
well he was Merrick III said that that
his severide had I'd really I kind of
pulled back and that severide you know
in my book I rode way back then I quoted
what severide said was I no longer
remember word for word but it was
awfully soft about somebody
I thought terrible things and and the
general idea that I was casting blame
and indicating that there was some kind
of little conspiracy there was already
thought there was in fact sera who had
been a friend of mine apparently took
that very very badly when I don't I'm
not surprised that he did and as I heard
it he never wanted to talk to me again
we go back to the Intelligence Committee
and as it's not directly involved with
the CIA there's a moment in your book
for Richard Helms comes out to
microphones and you're standing there
and he says things to you uses a word I
can't use her I can't either right now
it's in the book was explained that what
was that situation well I broke a story
probably the most important story ever
after it Watergate I came back and then
I my assignment became what we called
son of Watergate
around that time Seymour Hersh New York
Times had broken a couple of very
important stories one about the fact
that the CIA was used with domestic
surveillance of anti-war people secondly
a story from Chile about the attempt the
attempt to overthrow Allende the
left-leaning President of Chile and this
is my Watergate assignment was now over
CBS a once you take on some of the CIA
stuff and see if you can develop stories
like of a kind that Hirsch is doing in
the New York Times and so I became the
CIA FBI intelligence correspondent in
the in the course of that I managed to
break what I thought there was an
important story and that was that the
CIA had at some point been involved in
assassination conspiracies I went to see
Bill Colby the director of CIA and asked
him whether you people were ever all
involved in assassinations
he said not anymore at all so eventually
I went on the air with a report that the
president Ford had expressed some
concern of
the the his fear that the involvement of
the CIA and assassination conspiracy
would come out and cause a great fewer
well as a result of that the Senate
Intelligence Committee felt itself
obliged along with a new commission
headed by vice president Rockefeller
obliged to go into that they were
propelled into an investigation of
assassination conspiracies the chief one
of which was against Fidel Castro of
course and with the result that Richard
Helms who had been both first deputy and
then director of the CIA during the
period when these things were happening
and who was now our ambassador in Tehran
was called back twice from there to
testify and I can realize as I look back
on it that he associated me with all the
trouble that had been caused for him he
wouldn't have had to done have had not
broken that story and so when he came to
testify before the Rockefeller committee
out in the Rockefellers office in the
old executive office building he came
out and I was staked out there with
other television correspondents with
cameras ready we would ask all the
witnesses when they came out would they
care to say something in front of our
microphones and so when when Helms came
out of the meeting after three-four
hours of testimony which could not have
been very pleasant for him came out i
unknowing went up there mr. homn can you
come here where we have the microphones
and he turned to me and he began calling
me these unprintable and certainly
unrepeatable names that you have
referred to and with the wire services
all around the next story in the paper
next day was the way in which Richard
Helms
had denounced me we later made our peace
as an indeed uh and he had made peace
with all my adversaries of us on up to
and including Nixon and and now becomes
an IKE and have lunch we can talk about
playing tennis maybe both of us are now
too old to really play it very well but
somehow that era is done
and somehow you look back on it and say
that was Ben I was struck though by the
word that he use and wondered why as CIA
director we were using language like
that in the public place like that I
mean I don't mean to be a prude but I
just was did it surprise you he has a
bowled me over I bet I was totally
unexpected him coming the first of all
that he would begin denouncing me as a
person at all I just met not made that
connection that was in his mind clearly
that he would not have been standing
there
had I not broken that story and so he
was very very angry baby he had a right
to be not to play games but the word
that he used begins with a see later on
in your book you you talk about
collaborating with the CIA
yes what does that mean did you
collaborate with CIA yeah I collaborated
the CIA the way I got the word is
collaborated where I collaborated with
the State Department the way I
collaborated with anybody in government
if you are stationed abroad as I was for
about 20 years or so Soviet Union
Germany go into countries like Poland
Hungary and all the rest of it you want
to go and talk to American
representatives there I would talk to
people in the embassy then I would also
try to find out who was a CIA station
chief because they were frequently
better informed for my purposes then
then the State Department people and I I
once were accused you know of
collaborating with this year as the CIA
is an organ of the American government
has information which I may want in the
vikon yet I hope to get it and there
were other in one case for example CBS
wanted me to do a documentary on the spy
scare in Germany there was a period in
West Germany when every third person
there seemed to be an East German spy
and they were not taking it seriously
enough I was asked to do a documentary
about it and the CIA was also concerned
about the Germans not really taking
seriously enough the spy menace offered
helping and a managed to get me to meet
with an East German defector and East
German intelligence defector from the
Stasi as a service was called and they
arranged for me
to interview him well I was very helpful
if it served their purpose to give me
what I needed for a documentary where I
was doing that's fine and at some point
I wrote a piece for the New York Times
in which I said you know of course we
cooperate with the CIA
the question is only do you ever try to
get information give them information
which you have not already broadcast or
will not so many broadcasting have you
ever tried to get rewarded for it and it
provided to say to be paid for if you
are merely dealing with CIA personnel in
the same way that you would deal with
any foreign service personnel as as
sources of information sources of
possible help why not yes and that's
true I could do that
did they ever offer you any money and
did you ever take any money buddy ever
offered me money and I never took any
money I learned later from getting from
a Freedom of Information application
which where I got my CIA file that at
one point the Allen Dulles was when I
was in the Soviet Union and I was doing
a lot of reporting for soldier Union and
came back from there it appears that
there was some discussion as to whether
to offer me a job as a Soviet analyst in
the CIA somehow before the offer was
made they thought that are robbing the
greatest ethical dilemma in your career
Poland Russia and Jewish immigrants 1959
I was working on a documentary for ed
Murrow CBS reports on what Poland was
like now after the war after Stalin a
little bit of freedom all of that now
there were the camera co-producer and we
spent a month roaming around the country
just getting a feeling for what Poland
is like we did schools we did
agricultural settlements with all kinds
of things and in the course of our
wandering around the country we came in
a little town near the Soviet border we
came upon a very strange site of a group
of people piled on top of horse-drawn
wagons with what seemed to be all their
possessions
in the fount of a caravan there was like
a scene from fiddler in the roof
and I went up to them and found that
they were Jews whose Polish and Yiddish
and I interviewed them in Yiddish which
I could do for the purpose and they
explained that they had lived in a
little piece of Poland which had been
annexed by the Soviet Union at the end
of the war and they were felt trapped
there and that they were now free that
we've gone to Poland and they were told
as we go on to Israel and they will get
anywhere to go to station to Vienna for
being to Israel I thought was quite
remarkable because as far as I knew at
that time there was no Jewish emigration
from the Soviet satellite Empire allowed
in order not to antagonize the Arabs all
right so I was quite peculiar went back
to Warsaw and they want to see the
Israeli Minister who was a friend of
mine and I said I was so a bunch of Jews
gone the way to Israel how how is that
possible
he said you saw them you interviewed
your film of them saying that well mr.
Schurr since you know so much I will
tell you some more and then you decide
what you will do these people come from
far loved Poland and experto Soviet
Union they hate to be there they want to
lead we managed to make a very
confidential arraignment I mean
arrangement among the Israeli Polish and
Soviet governments that they would be
quote repatriated unquote to Poland but
would not stay in Poland but would then
leave for Israel Soviet said we'll go
for that it will do it unless it becomes
known it becomes known it ends and so he
said go into your story and you will
leave a few thousand Jews in the Soviet
Union if that's what you want to do and
I felt quite tormented by that and you
know ends have this can of 16 millimeter
film and I kept looking at it we were
shipping film every day of what we were
doing and I said let me hold onto this
for
moment the hell downhill for a day two
three four days never quite deciding
that I wouldn't use it but not doing
anything about I avoided making a
principled decision I just allowed
myself to remain confused about it and
in the end we didn't ship and we didn't
include it in our documentary when I
came home to New York I went to see
Mauro feeling a little guilty and I told
him the story and I told him that I had
more or less suppressed a little
interesting Philip that would go in the
story about Poland and Edie said I
understand why would it have been
ethical to have reported that if it led
to their deaths are led to their
inability to leave totalitarian
situations Brian that's that's the kind
of question is has haunted me all my
life say I have worked on this ethic but
what I legitimately legitimately come by
I have no right to suppress I'm an agent
of readers listeners ISM and I don't say
can't censor myself off it's bad taste
oh I know that we don't do things like
publishing names of rape victims or a
certain kind of constraints on what we
do but who am i that i may deny
legitimate information to the people
who've sent me there to find out what's
going on for them is it and he skinned
off me that the few thousand Jews won't
get where they want to go maybe that was
gonna come out I knew it I don't know is
a haunting dilemma and although I acted
at the time I would not at this point
say that I knew what I was doing or why
I was doing I would not I would not
justify my own actions I just did it let
me ask you about that because you
mentioned in here that Joe Califano was
your attorney and your friend yeah and
that Jim Shore the congressman from New
York was were you in his home you met
your wife
what if you
some of the body than one of those
people you think he'd report it well
depends it depends that's another good
question it depends on the circumstances
if these are social social relations as
such to me our regard is privileged
people have to be able to talk freely to
each other and theirs so I will
sometimes say on social you may talk
freely it's off the record so what
you're leading to is the other ethic the
off-the-record ethic how far should
report a goal and accepting and being
willing to enforce off-the-record
confidences and that is very subtle and
can be a very very big problem it's not
as big a problem for me as it is for a
lot of people I know but I generally in
this trade been called the
quintessential outsider that is to say I
don't hang around the saloons I don't
hang around these little places where
very important people tell you little
tidbits of things so and so forth I
generally come by my information in ways
that I don't have to have to worry about
but yeah every once in a while if
somebody says to you you're wrong and in
order for you to know yet you're wrong
about this or that you'll have to accept
an off-the-record confidence and if I
consider it important enough to do then
I will attention to it I don't have a
rule of thumb after all of these years
each case is another case Barry
Goldwater William Paley General William
Quinn and Sally Quinn yes what did they
add up to yes stationed in Germany and I
happened to be in Germany in 1964 on the
eve of the Republican National
Convention in San Francisco where it was
clear that Senator Barry Goldwater was
going to be nominated and CBS asked me
of the for the Saturday evening program
a television program but just before the
convention open to do a little synopsis
of what was going on in Germany it was
understood that there were German
right-wing people were greeting the
possibility of having a right-wing
person
elected president and so what was a view
from Germany and so I I did that and the
cost of looking into that I discovered
that senator Goldwater had plans
immediately after his nomination
the flight to Stuttgart Germany and
spend a vacation there with his old
bridge playing friend general bill Quinn
and where were they're gonna do this
then we're going to do this at what was
now an American Recreation Center
bestest cotton but which had also been
Hitler's favorite retreat before the end
of the before the end of the war the
idea that somebody who was running for
president you knighted States was spent
his first day as candidate flying off to
Hitler's favorite place in Germany
struck me as very odd and I expressed
that in an in the story that I did it
went on the air on the Saturday night
Goldwater took a very badly Goldwater
thought that I was part of some
Eisenhower Perry plot against him it's
all had to do with the fact that Bill
Scranton the Pennsylvania was still
fighting throughout his a nomination
without much hope it was believed
however that he was supported by
Eisenhower and parody was a friend of
Eisenhower so you could build a
conspiracy on what I didn't know at that
time that my story seemed to fit into
that pattern and so he got very angry
Goldwater did and he called the press
conference denounced us and not terms as
as unprintable as dick Helms but
recently unprintable and and there was I
having made trouble for CBS now this was
1964 twelve years later when I left CBS
and I wanted to write a book because I
am the kind of reporter I am wanted not
only my view of things involving me but
the view of my antagonist I went and I
did an interview with bill Paley on tape
he had his own tape recorder running I
had my tape recorder running and the
first the first question was mr. Pelham
why did you want to fire me is it Dan
I've been trying to fire you for 12
years ever since coke border was he has
supporter of Barry Goldwater's in a big
way no he was not as for he was that he
was that he was a supporter he would
have been a supporter of of Scranton
governor Scranton because he was a
friend of Eisenhower but that was
particularly that was exactly what made
him so vulnerable
was that you could build all of that
into an anti Goldwater conspiracy you
allude in here to another practice
during the Martin Luther King years and
the demonstrations of getting Stokely
Carmichael's of this world to be
incendiary yes first let me ask you this
because you're kind of a little doing
them but did you used to get paid at CBS
on the number by the number of times you
go in here no you never got a fee if
you've got your on evening news
oh no well the idea of fees for
performance went out somewhere in the
50s do you never had that on top but but
to be perfectly frank Lee you brought
the reward that one six and television
is not money it's exposure I wanted to
be on television wine this is the name
of the game or boy what are you there
for I mean everybody has a story that
you have a 23 24 minutes CBS Evening
News and everybody has something he
wants to get on the air and pushes very
pushes very hot to get on the air and I
at that time having been assigned to
cover a civil rights struggle and all of
that it became immediately apparent to
me for a while we are covered hearings
where people proposed a Marshall Plan
for the cities they proposed doing
things desegregation a whole lot of
other things television tend to get
rather bored with do good things
after a while they want to hear
something which will make their
listeners sort of sit up and take notice
and all the rest of which meant that the
kind of thing that got on me that got on
the air if you wanted me on the air was
having somebody who said burn baby burn
know we're gonna burn down your cities
over an erectus or that and we're gonna
tear off this and all of that was
marvelous and if you get that kind of
thing
from people like Stokely Carmichael or H
rat Brown will manage a talk on militant
language which works for them and works
for us
the correspondence could they wouldn't
it was something like that oh boy oh boy
he that's really rough and all and all
the rest of it and so to complete that
story in February of 1968 the Reverend
Martin Luther King came to Washington to
hold the press conference and announce
at poor people's March on Washington
which he was organizing but did not live
to see himself it gave a press
conference my colleagues and I from the
networks were there and he told them
what was planned there was set up as
place called resurrection city in the
shadow of a Lincoln Memorial and they
were trying to bring home to America the
problem of poverty in America and so
what did we do we did what we normally
did how violent do you plan to be are
you going to stop the gonna block the
bridges the way they're doing in the
anti-vietnam moratorium arch huh and he
would fend off these questions
and finally were they when the press
conference was over my camera crew was
packing up I waited for them to go back
to them the office with them and I
noticed the King dr. King sitting there
out on the podium looking very very sad
and I walked up to and said you don't
seem happy sir there's no missus sure
I'm not happy and you upon the reason
they say you try to think this press
conference and try to get me to say
militant things and violent things but
I'm trying to be anti violence and you
keep doing that and you'll put on
television all the most militant people
in our movement and you will elect them
as all leaders and then they'll be a
riot here or a riot there zone and you
will not know the part that you played
in promoting that a little shudder went
through me and I recognized that he had
a point there if you had it to do over
again would you not ask those questions
I can't so I I it's so nice to say now
that I'm old and wise I know better and
so on and so forth I remember myself as
somebody very very anxious to get on the
air and the way to get on the air was
with militant people another little bill
pilly story in here you talk about an
interview that you had where you explain
to him about reverse shots yeah but then
I want to quote what you said you said
bill Paley did not understand quote that
television relies on small deceptions
yes unquote explain all that well I
spent a lot 1953 when I was offered this
job to come to work at CBS and leave the
world of newspapers I came that became
to New York and I looked at television
and I saw people on I saw what they were
doing realize they were talents there
which were not like just the talents of
being able to write a story and so I
asked a young producer I said now for a
newspaper man going into television news
what is the secret of success right he
looked at me and he said the secret of
success is sincerity if you can fake
that you got it made right that was my
first word then I began to discover that
in order to be able to do the news on
television you have to play along with
little bits of illusion I mean not only
the illusion of putting makeup on you to
make you look a little nicer than you
ordinarily look or to be able to have
the right camera angle all the rest of
it learn to use the teleprompter which
is a special art in itself that requires
that when you're looking at teleprompter
you have to it every minute or so look
down because it seems more natural you
can't be expected to remember everything
so there's nothing there to look at but
the mere gesture looking down makes it
seem much more natural and then this
could there's hell business all of this
of the so-called cutaway shots the
reaction shots and this in the story
that you are alluding to the story of my
having done a documentary on East
Germany for CBS that concluded with an
interview with the East German Communist
boss Walter over
who did who took unkindly to some of the
questions that I asked and events we
stopped in a great rage began boiling me
out in German and finally he says
loosest but ended this interview is over
and stalked out of the room with the
camera running which I thought was
wonderful because I was a better ending
than I could have supplied through that
kind of thing and when shortly
thereafter the show was went on the air
and shortly thereafter bill Pelle had
his annual meeting with European
correspondents in Paris and at this on
this occasion sit down I was another
great show you did a nice Germany and
you know what would impressed me most
about it I said no sir he said it was a
calm serene look that you kept giving
this guy when he was bullying you out
and I giggled
I said sir you understand that the shots
that you saw me reacting was shot long
after he had left the room and Paley
said how do you do that
I said what the cold reaction starts you
know he's their standard reaction shots
that we do at the end of every interview
that we do his show me reaction shots my
colleagues around the table we're
getting a little edgy at this point
that's all right the boss wants the
reaction shots sores like this you're
doing an interview and at the end of the
interview you either have sympathized
with the person you interviewed or you
don't care much about it or you don't
like it at all
so you basically do three reaction shots
all within a minute one is for the
interview that you've been very
sympathetic very sympathetic can you
loan one is it kind of a neutral one one
is food I like over if you go you know
let it be known that you don't approve
of that Paley says to me but is that
honest well it's a great question but
this was his candy store where I learned
to do these things
so the sir it's part of the illusion we
have to have is it we were in an
entertainment business occupying a small
corner of it in which we tried to tell
people
what's going on in the world but we have
to use the tools of television in order
to be able to do it and it may not be
quite honest but it's what we do
did you agree with it did I agree with
it practice and the end it became so
routine so normal there comes a time
when you do things often you know if you
don't think about them anymore
it is so did I after that time do things
with cutaways we actually shot yes sir I
did
how hypothetical
how can a correspondent influence a
story with their own personal views if
he or she wants to well there's a very
crucial 15 or 20 seconds which is the
amount of time you're given at the end
of a produced piece will you stand in
front of the camera and sum up and you
can in those 20 seconds indicate that
while you reported to what these people
are said so on and so forth there's a
vast wealth of public opinion and it
doesn't believe that or does believe
that or that this will that you can
point the story in a certain direction
in those last 15 or 20 seconds I mean I
was well known at CBS for behavior being
able to use the end of saying what
something I would shoot the end before I
had put the story together and one of
which involve the investigation of
assassination conspiracies where they
ultimately discovered that while they
had talked about and often planned
assassination they had never really
succeeded in assassinating anybody it
was very odd and what the press
conference announcing all of his results
I stood up in front of the camera to do
my clothes wasn't and so it turns out
that Rich's Holmes and his people never
assassinate anybody but boy it wasn't
for want of trying and that those 10 15
seconds give a thrust to all the rest
did anybody at CBS News ever say to you
don't do that
well it was more like everything that I
did had to be edited in one way or
another an occasion they didn't there
was enough no I think I was accepted as
part of the game it's the way you are
compensated for how hard you've worked
on the rest of the story but I mean you
you've got the letters you heard how
upset some people were when they would
see correspondents that last 10-15
seconds it was never been an ever issue
when you worked there I mean that was
not a no not to my knowledge but you
know but CBS in his glory days was very
independent and proud of the fact that
their correspondents had a depth of
understanding of his story better than
the other networks and all of that and
so part of that was until there for
example Paley on the great pressure from
the White House once abolished something
which we did very well called instant
analysis we'd come on after Nixon
several of us rather mother and we do
analysis the White House didn't like our
analysis and they put a lot of pressure
on fairly and Paley for a while
abolished instant analysis tan Shore you
quote in here dick slant former
president of CBS News saying you're the
greatest reporter he ever had that's not
yeah but he also thanked you for that
close it
they also said I was one of the most
difficult people he'd ever had as well
yeah he was he was very it was very once
I was gone and he was getting ready to
write his memoirs and everything he
became very very kind people people do
he was a friend of mine we had we had
the most awful tussles between us at
times and yet he was as a head of CBS
News was clearly a protector and
defender of our institution on the whole
and I would not like that to be
forgotten
this August the 31st 2001 you will be 85
years old yes did you ever think you
would be an active working journalist at
this age no I didn't know I didn't how
do you feel how does it what's it like
how do you look at the world differently
today than you did 35 years ago
first of all I decided to I decided to
make an asset of my age and the way I do
that is to let it be known that what
people read about in history books as
they do read about in history book most
of these things I saw I was present at I
learned about I was alive at the time
and so now at NPR where I lead a much
more quiet life than I led at either CBS
or a CNN people accept me as not the
sage at least a person who is the
collective history the memory and
they'll come in and ask me questions
about what happened with with Joe
McCarthy whatever one person came in
once then Daniel remind me did you cover
the spanish-american war no you didn't I
guess you did that was about eight - in
1898 done excuse me all the rest of it
but but but for the rest well I like to
I like to write things in which I trade
on my age and the fact that I've been
there at times 50 years ago 60 years ago
you get 9 minutes on Saturday morning
right after the show starts with Scott
Simon yeah there was a time when that
had an influence on a president those
nine minutes well I um I think I think
what you're referring to is this for 15
years now Scott Simon and I have covered
the week's news on Saturday morning
starting after the newscast there at
9:06 a.m. Eastern Time somewhere about
second or third year into his
administration President Clinton decided
he wanted to give a radio talk on
Saturday morning and experimented with
what would be the right time for a
couple of weeks he did it at 9:06 a.m.
at precisely the moment when we were on
the air I and more as a joke than
anything else I thought it wrote him a
letter and said mr. president I don't
know if you're aware that you are
speaking at the same time that we are
speaking and so on of course you have a
right to do that if you want to do that
but it's not my idea of putting people
first
and I didn't hear anything for a while
and then I heard from George
Stephanopoulos called up and said hey we
were having a meeting
decide on a permanent time for the
president's talk on Saturday morning and
somebody said well how about nine oh six
that seems to be a pretty good time you
know what the president said no we can't
do that we can't do it at a Dan Schorr
they changed huh they changed 10 o'clock
they did change is that power or one
quarter of a century CBS six years at
CNN how many years 15 years at NPR 15
years Norwood NPR at CNN what was your
relationship with Ted Turner it was it
was it was rather mixed at the beginning
I was first editorial employee when he
decided to create CNN and we became very
friendly for a while
on a quite personal basis in the end I
don't know what happened but there was a
taken objection to some of the things he
did is for example he had this idea that
he wanted to have a jump on buying out
CBS he wanted to own CBS and of course
of that he asked the late former
Governor John Connally to be get
together some Texas oil money to help
him do that then in order to be nice
John Connally arranged during the
political conventions to have John
Connally as a guest commentator and
magnate as the guest commentators seated
next to me so that I would give him this
whole blessing of being a journalist I
said I wouldn't do that I wouldn't do
that
he's a politician you may like so I'm
not like him as a politician he's not a
journalist well they took exception to
that I thought I was not being
sufficiently cooperative what's the
difference between a journalist who has
personal views opinions and you give
them all through this book and a
politician has personal views and
opinions why couldn't the two sit side
by side and give their opinions because
when I give my personal opinions I
choose more you see to say viewpoints or
analysis but if
I won't argue about the world opinion
but when I do it is what does this thing
mean and how do I explain it to the
people and that's my whole purpose when
a politician does it he has a different
purpose he wants to run for office he
wants to influence some people a certain
way and therefore however respectable
the position of a politician is which I
don't know it's the thing is very rich
but never mind whatever it is a
politician has a different motive has a
different purpose in mind and I have
well then what's the difference though
between a journalist who has personal
opinions and his objective is to get on
television as you said and make lots of
money versus a politician whose
objective is to get power and then make
lots of money I mean it comes down to
you got two human beings with views why
do we make such a distinction between
the two I make a distinction I make and
I'm not even very happy about the whole
revolving door that goes on the people
are George Stephanopoulos who left the
White House ended up on ABC and for a
while at least I had the impression that
he was delivering on for ABC the same
kind of thing he would be saying if he
was speaking on behalf of Clinton at the
White House I think it's very confusing
I think that the now and then some
people make that make that change and do
it pretty well I think Bill Safire done
a great job of going from Nixon
speechwriter to columnist and all of
that but I do think that there really is
a difference between people to whom
information has no other purpose than
enlightenment in one form or another you
may not think you may not like my form
of enlightenment but I'm not trying to
influence any policy and the election or
anything else I'm just trying to tell
you how I think it is and whether John
Connally does it
he has other motives in mind you say it
Ted Turner's urging you were asked to
testify before a House Committee on
their violence right and then he went on
the air with an editorial on violence
why would you testify as a news person
about violence well that's a good
question I really I really thought a
great deal about it as to whether I
should or not and finally decided I
should because the question of violence
on television
concerns me a great deal in part because
I had some young children growing up at
that time and and I agreed to do it he
is it's fair to ask whether I should get
into the game of testifying when I may
have to cover the testimony of others on
this subject that's fair
but Ted Turner he was against violence
but he went on then to put wrestling on
television he also did something else
when the advice we had of those set-to
with him even on the question of islands
where we agreed pretty much that
something should be done about violence
on television he did an editorial of his
own on the network and saying that if
you agree with me there's so much
violence on television right your
Congressman and tell him to do something
about it well that now we're raising the
First Amendment question I believe
something should be done about it but by
an outraged public I don't believe that
Congress should do anything because the
Constitution says the Congress shall
make no law and and so I could not
explain
due to Turner that when you're talking
about Congress should do something about
it you've lost me because you've lost me
on First Amendment grounds and so we had
a little argument about that too a
couple of things some of them big some
small
you taught me where the word MIG came
from you're the MIG aircraft where did
it come from well this all happened
because because I was covered I was
recently back to Havana where it al 40
years ago I was there when Deputy Prime
Minister Anastas Mikoyan of the Soviet
Union came on the first important
official Soviet visit to Castro and I
recall this to him only recently when I
was Havana again and as you remember
that the question was whether you were
going to get MIG airplanes from the
Soviet Union he's right and you remember
you were talking to the right man
because McKeon's brother was a designer
of the made the MIG it mi is Michael Yan
and the G is gravich those were the two
designers of the big you lost two-thirds
of your stomach
a large part of my professional life was
clouded by the fact that I had a
duodenal ulcer and also was not just a
physical problem what it was was that it
would interfere with my making
appointments with my social life with my
planning trips because I never knew when
it was going to act up and so I was
always afraid and therefore lived my
life on a short-term basis until finally
they found and also which was close to
perforating went to the hospital had 2/3
of my stomach removed that I don't think
would have to happen today they are more
about ulcers 1955 and 1965 and and once
I was rid of the ulcer a whole life
change I'm in fact you know I often
wonder why I was I was nearing the age
of 50 and had never been married and I
think in part because when you worry
about that also you can't make
commitment was very interesting that a
year after that operation I met the
woman who is now my wife and didn't I
was able to make dinner appointments
without worrying whether I'd have an
ulcer attack when the time for dinner
came and your wife's name was Elizabeth
Bamberger you call her I call Holly
where did you meet her at the home of
Congressman Jim Sawyer who had was
having a dinner party to which I was
invited to towards the very end and run
into her there she was working then for
the anti-poverty program the Office of
Economic Opportunity which was part of
my beat so you know at first I thought
at least a source how today is Jonathan
and Lisa 3034 and just about 31 and what
do they do
Jonathan is has been a journalist a
newspaper journalist doesn't like
electronic journalism lives in Oakland
California and recently got a grant to
write a book about charter schools in
Oakland Lisa is in Boston graduated
Harvard and she is very busy working for
a consulting firm which deals with
taking
to employ people and helping them get
employed mr. Khrushchev of Russia yes
the most fascinating person I've ever
met
correct why well understand that when i
arrived in moscow 1955 to open the the
CBS bureau there i did not know what to
expect
I knew mainly of the years of Stalin and
Stalin had died in 1953 and the Soviet
Union was in the process of change which
I didn't fully understand but you soon
became clear that this awkward peasant
life but clever aggressive fellow fellow
Nikita Khrushchev had different things
in mind he wanted to bring the Soviet
Union somehow into the modern age while
still protecting communism and because
he was very outgoing would turn up at
diplomatic receptions all the time and
so it was possible to see him almost
every three or four days and check with
him how what was going on there was he
finally agreed to do a television
interview he appeared on CBS's Face the
Nation from his office in the Kremlin
the first ever interview with a Soviet
leader on television even on Soviet
television and wherever he went I would
go I was sort of a Soviet version of a
White House correspondent and was he
regarded as very amusing
sometimes referring to me as his Sputnik
because I was in orbit around him all
the time and then we have time there was
one very funny story with his job and
that was not one that was that was this
1956 was a very tense time Hungary was
going up in flames the war being fought
over Suez in the Middle East and whose
chef came back from an unusually long
vacation in October amid rumors that the
Soviet Central Committee was going to
make and take some drastic action or
some kind on either on Hungary or the
Middle East's and troops to Egypt or
something like that we couldn't even
find out on the conditions they were
there and as the Central Committee was
meeting or was going
to me and so because of my about a
special relationship with whose job I
undertook to find out at a reception I
went up to him when we talked about ten
minutes about his vacation he had had
Tito with him they hunted in the Crimea
and all arrests finally I said mr.
Khrushchev you think I could go down to
the Crimea must be beautiful there now
and paralysis of course you can notion
to somebody just
reynad but I have a problem maybe you
can even help me with a problem my
capitalist bosses back in New York CBS
had told me that I can't leave Moscow
because of rumors there's going to be a
central committee meeting and I don't
even know what to tell them so I was
wondering and he lowered his voice very
theatrically and said you want to go on
vacation mister sure when tomorrow
how long two weeks and you are afraid
that in those two weeks you may miss a
meeting of the Central Committee that's
exactly it
you can go on your vacation you mean
you're not going to mr. short if
absolutely necessary we'll have the
meeting without you
this is the cover of the book our guest
has been Dan Schorr for six years and
the making this book called staying
tuned a life in journalism thank you
very much thank you